[Music]
such a big year a lot of milestones in
your life your wedding and meeting and
made some has been such a huge success
but let's talk about tonight while
you're here celebrating tonight with
American Express I'm so excited to be
here tonight to celebrate this cool new
feature that American Express has it's
I'll pay it planet it really puts the
power into the card holders hands you
mentioned I just got married
planning a wedding a lot goes into that
and having this feature when I was
getting married would have been really
helpful that plan the bigger purchases
like wedding venue flights things like
that but also being able to pay for
quick things right away so that you know
you don't get surprised by your
statement
et chatted with Samir Wiley in New York
to celebrate the launch of peut Planet a
new feature from American Express that
gives you control in how you pay for
things
six months and a little over six months
into the marriage so how is this new
plane gonna make travel easier for you
guys and I'm sure you're planning
another trip in the future absolutely we
love to travel if I'm going you know say
Italy which I went for my honeymoon
right hey oh they have great food there
and one of the things that I loved was
their olive oil it's just take it a bit
don't worry yeah you can just pay for
that and pay it right on the app that's
awesome
I don't you know but October 4th is
actually the one year anniversary since
you guys announced your engagement did
you even realize that no okay well now
you really have fun well I mean how
would you guys celebrate something like
that you know I
I don't know it's it's been a year of
celebration yeah you know what I mean so
I'll have to remind her I wonder if she
knows if anybody is into the same things
I am like having control and you know
just cool new features this is for them
and go to American Express Sox complex
pay plenty
[Music]